guess who has arrived
hey mama potato bear
freaking papa with the new haircut you
look skinnier do i yeah what about me
you look way skinnier liar
why he's so happy
liar
i never know if he's telling the
two-thirds line
shut up
he's such a liar white skinny i promise
swear to god you take a dice i swear to
god
right nice nice
all right so i said
everything that your freaking
crazy fat man cravings head
and where did we end up right now
99 ranch what do you mean
because i was just saying how like
you're gonna lose this leaning out
competition that you and i have going on
because you always crave fancy ass food
i crave it but this is the most
discipline i've ever been and why is it
the most discipline you've ever been
does that have a coach now no you've
always had a coach
no this time i have a real coach no
you said it was because i'm so
disciplined and i'm keeping your ass on
track
that's the real reason no what's the
reason
what is it you talk so much
honestly that is the real reason because
there's a couple weekends where like
when i'm not around you're always eating
at a restaurant guess what i didn't eat
nothing bad
i didn't eat nothing bad i stuck to my
macros i even plugged in the bowl of pho
that i ate
everything that i did eat at a
restaurant the hot gal and all that
stuff i put it in my fitness pal
so huh girl [ __ ] you're on a
diet and you're [ __ ] consuming hug
out it's the most uh macro friendly dim
sum ask david he knows you are a fat fat
man i can't wait to watch you lose no
it's not look at this look at that it's
already coming in
the fat i see it someone's coming
somewhere
let's go shop for your fun ingredients
you [ __ ]
king boy
okay mr man what's the first thing on
the list that you're gonna get so i
gotta look for a
instant pub broth because i saw this
online
and there's some bug broth it's just
instant made out of powder and one of
them i found it was zero grams of fat so
that's the toughest thing for me
is finding things with like a very low
fat to protein ratio
and i always want something soupy and
like savory and lots of flavor but those
things usually are high in fat so i
don't look like that
look at this why would he torture
himself like this look at all this
delicious
oh
delicious ramen
and udon instant udon
[Music]
[Music]
are you kidding me dude where's the [ __ ]
dude hey what kind of asian chips are
those where okay so we got these yeah
and then we got these sprinkles oh we
got sour onion pringles
oh pringles where is it
so we have located look at this
rice noodle zero grams of fat you know
what i'm talking about
3.4 grams of protein that's pretty good
47 gram what grams of carbs oh that's
pretty good that's really good i mean
that's high carb but
no but you know i mean the facts is what
gets me you did the worst thing by
coming here when you're hungry i know
but i'm very disciplined right now
because i finally hired a really good
coach
so
we already heard the truth
bart
what we already heard the truth
well i'm gonna go with the sun boy
what is that so this is salted mustard
you know that dish that you like from
happy fam the vegetarian restaurant yeah
they stir fry with this
so papa looks for the fat boy
ingredients
i found this
broom and these are honestly the best
home in
indoor
rooms you'll ever use they sweep
everything up and it's in one clean
sweep too
ever since um i was introduced to it
i've never had a different
version of a broom in my house ever
again
what are you looking for now i feel like
what i want
is so close yet so far
what do you want what is it this is more
of a soup base i'm looking for instant
pho cause this thing says you need to
cook it for an hour i'm not trying to do
that for an hour i'm looking for
instance what if you just buy it for
later
i just know i'm not gonna have time to
do that kind of stuff i see
what did you find so i found this pho
broth in a can doesn't look the most
appetizing but
it's better i could actually count my
calories and
i want to get some sort of hearty thing
and this is the closest thing i can get
okay this 99 ranch in monterey park is
so nice now i haven't been here in like
years look at this
it never looked like this before look at
all this
everything's organized and orderly
look at that
i'm blown away especially over there
the seafood section like you could
literally just touch the seafood it
would be like like not like this but it
would just be on display and you could
just like see the fish is kind of just
swimming around it was nuts
nuts i tell ya
okay plot twist what happened
so as i was going around looking for
ingredients to put a fuzz together
um
you felt that the cans looked janky it
looked janky and it just the flavoring
wasn't going the right way versus i was
like oh cool i found some sliced chicken
thigh that'll go nice in the soup but
then this with the beef broth doesn't
really go together and then i saw
veggies although i just throw some
veggies in there oh bok choy at this or
the rice no that looks good i'm like ah
the beef broth doesn't look like it fits
this this this
looks like it fits way better
so i'm gonna go with that route oh you
know we should buy then
instant rice
oh just to have at home yeah
have you ever had greek flavored yogurt
before
no
come here it tastes like greek people
greek flavored oh my god yogurt yo hurt
your head hurts yo hurt
your hurt
yo furt
and how do you say this
and
well if you guys want to know what
greeks taste like
the amount of concentration
this man has been here for the past what
what happened
i think i found something
okay look
0.5 grams of fat right yeah it's pretty
much zero yep
17 grams of protein what is this
egg noodle yeah
that's [ __ ] cool that sorcery
they're not even trying to be healthy
i wish your face was played up but no
this is real bart face
he's really happy and surprised
dude i'm gonna eat this what the [ __ ]
give a few of them yeah
let's go
all right you can find it here 99 ranch
you saw it here first everybody
there might be no typo
oh scan it with your phone first
remember that it changed no it's not
it's not an iphone it's the real real
damn player
look at this scientist over here look at
how much noodles i get to eat
you know how many uh
grams of protein is in there
uh 40.
pretty close like 30 something
okay i can't wait to see your finished
product i'm going to leave you alone
until it's done okay focus
okay papa you just said that you're done
yup like a disc
big old bowl of ramen i got miso wow
i got bok choy i got enoki mushrooms
damn i ate like a peasant today do you
want to know what i eat what'd you eat i
got like this little zigzag action i'm
saying
[Applause]
that a little bit of that action in
there
[Applause]
okay some grilled chicken okay two bowls
of protein cereal
yes you can have water
two bowls of protein cereal yeah two
scoops of uh barbara brigade protein
some of these nuts
i'm about to have two of these ropes i'm
absolute garbage you big candy okay i'm
gonna eat okay it's so hungry i get it
what's what i'm about to eat you're
about to take a picture of what you're
about to try and then i'm going to eat
how many pro how much protein is this
let me take a look
i think like 80 huh
you want to see
yeah
i mean i'm looking at the dish if you
had two bundles of it and that was
already 30 or 40.
that chicken
yeah [ __ ] i didn't finish that
can i finish food
did you just ask me that oh you
[ __ ] you know what i'm gonna i'm
gonna wait to the end of this and see if
you ate it all okay fine can you take
this from me
you just said i'm gonna eat i know i'm
gonna take a picture hurry
your uncle is cuckoo bird you know that
do you wanna
do take a picture of these noodles
you and the noodles yeah
there you go
you want some no thank you it's actually
pretty good
just need a little bit more of this
[Music]
noodles you like eggnog yeah i love egg
noodles
yeah yeah take another bite
that man will never suffer
why
don't you say that drinking soda
got it in my car
fancy ass noodles
whoa
i'm eating sour patch kids the extra
sour ones and these are actually extra
sour
whoa
okay on that end thank you guys so much
for watching i'm gonna enjoy
this duty brains company
we'll talk tomorrow